hey guys i'm ryan right and alyssa be
crazy so today we're gonna unbox this
one up box that I got kombat vs month
Alyssa please do the honors of unboxing
battabox item number one coming up I'm
ready put out the hand it's a dragon
ball that's super cool it's a dragon
ball you know you get enough of these
and you can rule the underworld I forgot
what the goal was if you got all the
dragon boats but wow look at that high i
own a personal Dragon Ball now losers is
it as um it is a stress it is the
stressful nifty you know on on Christmas
I was with my girlfriend and her father
saw that Veronica gave me a stress ball
is one of my presence and and then I
said in front of the dad I never knew
that squeezing balls would make me feel
so good and did you really than everyone
laughs everyone laughs and it was just
the highlight of the day on Christmas I
think things got worse in front of my
parents actually I would send know many
a worshipper ready yeah no no good
kitchen mama peanut butter and jealous
peanut butter and jealous indeed it's a
sweatband no sweat it catch them all
with that you that's amazing
I choose you super Jew that's when you
Pokemon oh you super Jew superchip
that's how he talks anyway oh my god I
gotta patches on some [ __ ] this is
awesome what do you got going oh I don't
know you know what do you have it
there's gotta be a whale reckon like
human centipede this in some way oh cool
maybe I can put it on um like dude this
would be like Deadpool theme because
like Deadpool invading the Avengers Oh
got it got it there you go BAM did it
that's cool 10 bucks you are
continuously impressing me okay this is
a little big one you ready a little bit
little big one alright let's find out
the toys just keep getting better
adorable he's a happy someone asked me
what my top five favorite comic book
characters are and I listed Wolverine is
like number three or something I love
will ring hey bub yeah cute is little
rain is like a little Q over eight I
know at the door he's like a little tiny
feels like a little smiley Wolverine
he's like a little Chinese over here so
it's like a donut and now he has a donut
food being oh we should so get donut
let's make that a thing let no not a
thing that we do but let's make it but
every time I mean to make it over once
in a while occasion not dead i will see
you like once every two months we'll
start every video with the donut just
give me the next thing a pin a pin oh
look at that you recognize that ah that
is the sword of wait which one is that
that's the Skyward Sword
I'll exact one a day that is its link
sword from Skyward Sword it is the sort
he has yeah it was a link sword I forgot
the name of this well there's the master
sword this guy red sword not gonna lie
haven't played zelda is winwaker what
yeah you need to catch up look at that
oh yeah haha another pin that I oh and i
have several pins and I pin my cats with
them they don't like it oh oh I just got
what it was super smash oh my god that's
awesome what is it is this sticker
that's really cool that's a really cool
[ __ ] sticker hold on you should put
that on your computer that's a really
cool [ __ ] staggered awesome I will
repeat that is a really cool [ __ ]
sticker I love the Pikachu yeah yeah
it's badass also give it a tattoo
they're all using their powers yeah I
know I didn't catch that I'm sorry next
present come on okay it's the shirt
ready I'm ready whoa whoa oh you're
gonna be jealous crazy sauce watch you
look at it and winwaker link to link
funny arata movie cartoon oh that's
awesome yeah you did I wanna bucks is
good your son of a [ __ ] 1up box wow
what wow you know what Oh boom
shaka-laka-laka boom well anyway guys
yeah if you wanted to get a 1up box and
be as awesome as me by collecting one up
boxes you should go to the referral link
in the description box where you can get
a 1up box yourself dude and you do it
you're gonna get off this [ __ ] shirts
and if you get a 1up box instagram the
real rejects yeah show us that you got a
one-out box hag sir ryan sir ryan right
um you
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can um you can subscribe to the real
rejects you could you could do that you
could also check out a list of me
crazies channel you could also do that
it's good channel yeah I get drunk on
Tuesdays did you know yeah you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine and periscope not not for me though
I don't do fairs go yet but I will other
things though I just
I was like my box I know you do it's
amazing you get all of this stuff cuz i
am the cool stuff well this is squeezing
balls good night